hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
how to quantify 200 metabolites with one
lcm sms method
i'm susie valdez of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by agilent
now let's get started before we begin
i'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you'd like during the presentation to
do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational
and offers free continuing education
credits click
on the continuing education credits tab
located at the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain
your credits without further ado i now
present today's
speaker dr christoph clavins deputy
head of the proteomics and metabolomics
facility research center for molecular
medicine
of the austrian academy of sciences for
a complete biography on dr
clavin's please visit the biography tab
at the top
of your screen dr clavins welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
hello everyone uh thank you so much for
the kind introduction the opportunity
to present the work that we've been uh
doing for the
biggest part of the last year so
basically what we wanted to do is to
really find the method that we can
quantify as much metabolize as possible
and i hope that you can find our
approach useful
and also implement some of the things
that we've done here also when you want
to
set up similar method in your lab or
your institute
so to put things a bit more in
perspective what we're doing here i
would like to give also a bit of
introduction about our institute
so sam stands for the research center
for molecular medicine of the austrian
academy of sciences
and we are located in austria in vienna
and we are quite privileged to have this
really unique location so we are in the
center of campus of medical university
vienna
and also there's also next doors of
vienna general hospital
so we're really embedded in the in a
biomedical research here
and there are 10 research groups here at
sam and there's around 200 people
working here
and they're truly international so we
have people from 48 nations here
and besides research groups we also have
three facilities
a sequencing facility compound screening
facility and proteomics metabolomics
facility
and at sam we really pursue the free
mining basic
life science research to really achieve
the maximum scientific innovation to
improve the health care
we also trained the new generation of
biomedical scientists
by having a phd and power tech program
here
and that said what we really stand for
and strive for is excellence quality and
responsibility
in everything that we do what i really
would like to point out is also the
super cooperation mode
that we're working so we've really tried
to
collaborate ever with everyone and as a
facility it also means that we are
involved in a lot of the research that's
done here in our institute
and proteomics and metabolic facility
is a team of 10 highly skilled and
dedicated scientists
and what we do we use liquid
chromatography coupled to mass
spectrometry
to provide analysis of proteins and
metabolites
in a given biological system so as i
said our lab
mainly uses mass spectrometry and we
have a wide range of mass spectrometers
available for metabolite analysis this
includes
high resolution mass spectrometry based
on arbitrary technology
such as qx active and fusion lumos and
we also have
triple quadruple systems from waters and
also from adrenaline
that i'm going to talk about later
and so this access to this wide range of
mass spec instruments
will also provide this opportunity to
set up different workflows for metabolic
analysis
we have workflows where we really try to
profile
several hundreds of metabolites or
lipids
we also have capabilities to run
commercial kits for metabolic analysis
and this includes
appearance at kits from company
biocrates
and on the other hand we also can focus
really on particular pathways for
instance we have assays
for tca and eurea cycle and we can use
our high resolution mass spectrometry
capabilities
to also facilitate isotope tracing
analysis which we have
successfully implemented and used in the
past years
and also we provide our expertise to
provide
customs analysis for small compounds
this can be metabolites or also small
molecules such as drugs
and we are not the biggest facility
so what we have is around 3 000 samples
per year
and the major sample type that we see
here is the cell samples
this is one of the systems that we use
the
most in our institute we also have
experience in biofluids
such as plasma serum and urine we also
analyze tissue samples
and also organic compounds so this could
be either compounds from organic
synthesis
or commercially both drugs
so as you've seen we have aspects
already we have experience with them
and the question is why would we need to
another method
so the question answer that this
question is quite simple the general
trend that we see
is that the more is better the more
metabolites you can measure
the more information and value it gives
to the biological research
and there is a one particular project i
would like to point out
where it's really essential to have this
wide range metabolite analysis provided
with the one robust system and
instrument
and this project is resolute and it
stands for
research empowerment on solid carriers
and this project is funded by the grant
from innovative medicine initiatives and
it focuses on particular protein class
called solid carriers
or slcs in short and slcs are the
membrane proteins
that have an important physiological
function there are around
400 proteins in this in this
protein family and they're involved in
nutrient uptake ion transport waste
transport
and also in drug transport in the cells
however this protein family despite the
class despite that being so important
is really heavily understudied there's
around 40 percent of them
has there are around 40 without known
cargo or function
and resident aims to really characterize
and understand
understand these proteins more in detail
and one of the
tools that are used with the that
understand them
is overexpression and knockout cell ends
of those proteins so you could imagine
if you over express this protein
on a membrane then more things are
transported into the cell
for instance if it really transports
metabolites you would see more
in metabolism cell and vice versa with
the knockouts so once you knock out this
protein you would expect less
metabolism or transported molecule into
the
into the cell and in this regard so
metabolomics is really essential to
to that can identify those metabolites
that are transported with the given slcs
and but also if we talk about
overexpression knockouts
but also one for the vision is that once
you
overexpress those proteins and you have
increased
levels of the metabolites in the cell
and also a downstream metabolites of
this metabolite so metabolism products
of these metabolites
will be increased so you really want to
characterize the whole chain
of change that these are introduced by
overexpressing this
slc and this is a really large-scale
study
that aims to analyze several thousands
of cell culture samples
over a span of several years so we're
talking we live
five to six thousand samples in the in a
course of one into
one to two years and
our facility we were trusted with the
task to provide interstellar metabolite
analysis for the samples that will be
generated during this project
so this really set up some really
specific requirements for the method
that we want to use for this project
so first requirement was that we need
targeted method so we really want to
know
which metabolites we measure and if
there are
increased or decrease in transport we
know which exactly metabolites are those
we also want to have a quantitative
method so in our experience
quantification is really
a good tool to get the robust results i
really trusted
trust for trustworthy results
requirement was a robustness so we need
we needed a method that we perform
really stable over years so if we
measure the samples now
and we measure them within one year we
want to be sure that we get
exactly the same method performance and
exactly the same result because
once again this is really a large scale
study so also the coverage of
metabolites should be as broad as
possible
so not only to identify those
metabolites that are transported with
slcs
but also to identify the downstream
process or to see
how the whole metabolic pathways are
perturbed
by by transporting or increased or
decreased concentration of those
metabolites
and of course this message should be
suitable for cells
so we should be able to run sell
extracts with this method
also it's important the method we would
would use for this project
should be scalable in the sense that we
can measure
either six samples either 10 samples or
hundreds of samples of the same method
so we should not be limited by the
number of samples that we can measure
and also we want something that's
customizable so if we say that we need
to improve
include more methods sorry metabolites
in the method we could do it
or if we need to remove some metabolites
from the method we could do it
and also it was quite short method time
that was
allocated for us so we really needed to
have something we can set it up quite
fast
and to get to met all the requirements
were set for
us so then we looked around
if there's something already available
that we can use the starting point
and what we found was the agent
metabolomics dynamic mrm database and
method
so this method and database is based on
agelint 6470 triple quadruple systems
coupled with lc system infinity 2.
so what this message uses for separation
is ion pairing
separation mode so ion pairing is known
to be really powerful tool
to separate analyze with different
properties from
polar non-polar and in this method
tributal amine is used as ion pairing
reagent on the c18 column
and also i'm pairing this zone in the
field to be quite
unstable so and in this method there was
lots of thought and effort putting to
really make this separation method
stable
so there was a specific switching valve
or specific setup
that allows back flash of the column so
there's a switching valve installed in a
column compartment
and once the gradient is over it
switches and allows to back flush the
column after the gradient
and this really improves the stability
of the separation
and also you can see here that the
effective gradients are
24 minutes so this is when the
separation is happening then after those
24 minutes the wall switches
and its column is back separate
acetonitrile and afterwards
it's again reconditioned for the next
sample
so the whole method takes around 40
minutes or 40 minutes for analysis
and backflashing is for backflashing
acid natural is used
and for this method for detection
the the mrm or dynamic mrm mode is used
which means metabolites are
detected and measured around the
retention time when they elude from the
column
and as triputil amine is used as iron
current reagent
only negative ionization mod is possible
so this a bit
limits um the number of metabolites or
class metabolites you can measure with
this method
but also i want to point out here that
method is fully customizable so if
needed
you could include new metabolite tray
could remove the methods
so and methods comes
as it's installed it provides an ounce
of 290 metabolites
and it covers with a brick portion of
central carbon metabolism
you have such an important metabolite
like sugars amino acids nuclear bases
there
it really covers good the
landscape of metal pathways at this
point we also would like to show
or point out is what we unfortunately
figured out
a bit too late so the
the system is used to analyze phosphor
containing compounds and everything
stainless steel
and there is a specific column
observation procedure so basically what
it means
you flush your hplc system in your
column with the diluted phosphoric acid
overnight
and what it does it increases its
sensitivity and method performance for
phosphor
phosphorus containing compounds so you
passivate your system
and we learned it hard way that's
actually needed to do it
and here you can see the results before
we did it we really really possibly
puzzled why we cannot see atp at this
high concentrations
and afterwards we saw okay you need to
do this column observation
and then we could see this really
dramatic increase in sensitivity for
this particular compound
so to sum up this is the method how it
comes and this for us was really a
starting point right we said okay we
have the method
we have the setup that allows us to
detect
290 metabolites we have a good robust lc
method
there's a basic data processing method
coming with that
with indicated retention times with
integration parameters and so forth so
on and so forth
so method as is you could take some
really useful relative quantification
but what we wanted to do in our lab
really is to bring it to the next level
to really
achieve absolute quantitative workflow
for this method so this for us was a
starting point actually for our work
so the first thing that we did we really
carefully
evaluated the provided mrms so they
provide
there's mrms to detect 290 metabolites
and there's a quantifier qualifier
and we knew that for our purposes we
don't need qualifier so we just need
quantifier
so we really looked which mrna kicked
out to just have one mrm per compound
additionally we removed metabolites with
a bad and local performance
so those were really ones either with
the low sensitivity or really
with bad peak shapes and also we created
sums for metabolites that are not
separated by the hboxy system
so these were sugars and sugar
phosphates mainly additionally
we were able to include seven new
metabolites
ah sorry seven several new metabolites
these were seven alkyl carnitines
also folic acid and folic acid
metabolism
so at the end we ended up with 190
metabolites
in in the detection method
and if you want to achieve absolute
quantification you need to have
calibrations and if you want to have
calibrations you need metabolite
standards
so we really looked out there and to see
how much metabolized balance we can
buy commercially and we ended up with
having our own metabolite standard
library
of 190 metabolites so 130 metabolites we
get from company metasta in canada
then around 60 metabolites we got from
sigma and other metabolites we got
either we had them in house
or we got from other sources so we were
able to really purchase every single
metabolite we had the method separately
as a separate compound
to really establish our own standard
library
in-house so but there's a
aim for us was really to put all those
metabolites into one mix
to have all of them in one vinyl that
then could be used
to set up calibration groups but there
are
several let's say practical challenges
with that
so you cannot really put them all
together at once so the one challenge is
there that really
if you would just dilute them in equal
molar volumes
the highest concentration you would get
would be around 250 200
micromolar and for some metabolites it's
completely fine
but for some it's way too low so some
metabolites are quite
much higher concentration cell extracts
other thing is solubility
so how can we really mix these analyzers
have different solubilities together
so we thought about it what what to do
and the solution that we came up with
was experiments
that we called 22 point calibration
so the basic idea was here that we will
start for every single metabolite that's
relatively high concentration
of 500 micromolar and then have
one to two dilution for that one and
this we would repeat
21 times so then what we had with the
concentration of the range
from 500 micromolar to 0.2 picomolar
right and this experiment would allow us
to first of all assess
limited detection a limit of
quantification for methods because we
would really
see where we live with the sensitivity
or where we approach
limited detection it also would give us
some really
very valuable information about
calibration ranges
meaning we would know where
we would know where our samples stand in
this in this range of concentrations
but also get information about linear
range so meaning when the
instrument responds to linear and also
by dynamic range
and most importantly would also learn a
lot about solubility
there were set information provided
about some tablets where they are
soluble but for some it was really trial
and error
so it really gets a lot of value
information just from this one single
experiment
but again the practical limit remains
right you cannot just mix them all
together
as i mentioned before so what we did we
took all those metabolites and divided
them in four groups
and we divided them based on the
retention time so our
thinking was if we mix them together and
then the ones that come together on a
on a mass spec they would influence each
other similarly so the iron suppression
effects will be the same
or or effects on separation efficiency
will be the same
because at the end we have quite quite
high concentration so then we really
slice chromatogram
in four parts and then mix those
compounds that come
in a given part together and made this
22 point calibration
experiment so then we looked at results
and what we've seen that for more than
150 metabolites
the linear range was really good is
across three orders of magnitude
and for the majority of compounds the
limit of detection was below
0.1 micromolar so this really
good sensitive method that we had here
and here's one example that i want to
show for glutamine the result
amino acid and this is what you
typically would expect right that you go
up with the
concentration you see that there's kind
of saturation effect ionization so
the curve is not anymore linear and it
flattens out however it changes if we
start to implement internal standard
so if you start to build the ratio of
internal standard it again becomes
linear
so this really highlights importance of
internal standard for quantitative
workflow
it not only improves the precision
accuracy but also
improves the linear linearity for
calibrations
so then we have this calibration curve
we also run several
samples cell samples tissue samples
plasma samples to really see where they
sit
in this calibration range in this
calibration curve and based on this all
this information required
we really set up our calibration curve
or
and this will consisted of 10 points the
seven points what was so-called core
calibration
so this would be what would cover the
whole
sample that we had or this would cover
the range where the sample concentration
sits
and then we had three points what we
called service points so these would be
points
to be just in case if in some samples we
overshoot the calibration range or
this so the highest calibration the
highest service point was
two times higher than a core calibration
and also we had two extra levels in the
lower end
just to be sure that also when there's
lower concentrations we still will be
within the
calibration range so and this is
how it looks like then uh we double talk
scale
and we really try to be quite quite
equidistant with our calibration hard to
really have
that it's really nice to sit in the
middle our samples there
and all the compounds grouped in six
groups based on uh calibration
concentration
so majority of them was from
10 to 0.01 micromolar
and this really allowed us to set up
really nice and easy
workflow how to mix standards together
so now we
can really adapt range for every single
compound separately we can have some
premixes
that we take care of solubility issues
and then at hand mix everything together
and we have this one big
mix that we use for calibration
and if we look at the calibration
performance
so for majority of compounds or how we
had really good
calibration for performance so good in
this regard means
the r squared is higher than 0.95 and we
have at least six points in the
calibration curve
then there was around 60 compounds with
really acceptable and acceptable and
this means
the r squared is higher than 0.92 and we
have at least five points in calibration
and there were some compounds we really
had some problems with calibration
and this could or in some cases was
sensitivity issues so we were a bit on
the lower range so we had three points
or four places calibration curves and
some other lines we really start to
observe some
some issues with the stability the next
thing was as i mentioned before
internal standards are important and
there are several reasons for that it's
to get better precision to get better
accuracy
and also to improve linearity and first
when we started
to think about our internal standard
strategy we thought okay we're just
going to follow the same workflow as we
did before
so we screen for what are the internal
standards available there for this
metabolite
and we could found 43 compounds
separately commercially available
but the price tag was a bit too high for
us
i said okay what are other alternatives
and as an alternative
we thought about using c13 labels
metabolic extract
so there's a company it's a spinner from
university of vienna it's called
isotopic solutions
and they really sell c-13 labels
metabolite extract
from a c13 labeled yeast so you have all
the metabolism
in the yeast labeled with stabilized
with stable c30 label we also had uh
already good experience with some of the
commercial mixes from cambridge asap
laboratories and some of the
with metabolomics amino acid mix and
labeled carnitine mix
so this was the things that we started
okay with if we take these three
things then we would have a really nice
coverage of all the metabolites
and that we have in the method however
again was one
practical issue which was we really
didn't
know what are the metabolites in the
metabolism diseased extract
um and second problem was we don't know
how to measure them
because in instrument there is no
settings for that so
as as the method comes there is only for
unlabeled metabolites right there is no
settings for for c13 labeled tablets
so what we needed to do is really to
manually calculate
all the mrms for these internal
standards
so what we did first we looked in this
example for one amino acid
so we we looked what that mrm that is
provided in the method
then we really looked at the
fragmentation pattern so what is the
structure formula
of the intake molecule and the fragment
then we calculated what are the number
of carbons there in the fragment
and in the precursor molecule and then
added
the number of carbons to the mrm to have
this mrm pair
for all the internal standards and this
we did for all
all 190 metabolites we had in the method
and we screened
the g-stack script and really then
selected the ones with really good
performance
so what we ended up was that we with 68
internal standards in total so 44 from
well from this isotopically labeled
g-stack struct and then we had
24 from cambridge isotope laboratories
for commercial mixes
and next next thing we wanted to
optimize was really the concentration of
internal standard
you want to division that if you add
internals on the sample
so you add extra metabolites in your
sample so what can happen is that you
either
ruin your chromosome of separation by
overloading the column or also it could
affect detection
so what we did we looked at different
dilutions of internal standards so we
start with higher concentration of this
one to seven point five dilute and one
to one to thirty diluted
and first thing we look as well as the
separation efficiency what we can see
here is the example of isolating loyalty
so there should be two peaks
should be two separate amino acids and
the higher we go with this concentration
with terminal standard
the more the separation gets it's really
kind of gets this one peak
another example is going to seem so here
you should really have one nice peak
that we see it when we go with the lower
concentration
internal standard and then b gets split
at the moment that we increased internal
tunnel concentration
so this really showed us that the
highest concentration concentrations we
can go is one to ten diluted internal
standards
and not only that but we also looked
what is the precision
so what is rs zero frequent injections
repeated injections
so in general what you would like to
have for internal standard is as a
stable and
performant and as low
deviation between injections as possible
and here i plotted the
rsds of different dilutions and as you
can see that the
lowest rsd was for the highest
concentration which is quite
logical i would say and so we decided
okay we're going to
stick to this 1 to 10 dilution of
internal standard
even though we know that we sacrifice
chromatographic performance for
handful of compounds but this is a
compromise we were willing to take
so then with this method we analyzed
several sample types as i mentioned
and once we've seen that the method as
such is positively biased towards
intercellular metabolites
so we can see that we can detect more
metabolism cell extracts
we can also detect around 100 metabolism
tissue extracts
and the plasma will see around 70
metabolites so in our cases
being positively biased or cell actually
this is fine because cell extracts will
be the major sample that they're going
to work in our lab
also we were eager to see how it
compares with other methods right and
one of the methods that also we have
experienced and we have used in our core
facility
is absolute idq when atk is from
biographies and here we really compared
what are the analyzing can detect with
those methods and as you can see there
is some part that overlaps but there's a
big part that don't overlap with these
methods
but this really shows that methods that
truly um
complementary to each other so in be
people that i take it you have this big
fraction of lipids that are measured
that is not covered with asian dmr
method and other handle asian dmr method
we have
things like nucleotides sugar sugar
phosphates that are not covered by the
kid
there is a fraction of metabolites which
are male amino acids
that overlaps in both methods and if we
look at precision so what is rsd of
repeated injections
then it's really similar between two
methods and this is also not a big
surprise as both methods
use this triple quadruple as a technique
for detection
also the thing that we were concerned
was the retention time stability
so here i plotted retention time of
single sample across four batches
so every single batch consists of around
80 cell samples then we have
calibrations we have quality control
samples we have blanks
so it's around 100 120 injections per
batch
and here in these four batches you can
really see this retention
time is really really stable so there's
a serine which comes in the beginning of
uh of the chromosome there's nad in the
middle and atp at the end
and you can see that across the run in
between the runs
the retention times are really really
stable
and actually what we learned in our lab
is that we can rely on retention time so
much
that if we see that there are some
issues or it shifts that indicates that
something is wrong our hplc system so
either the cleaning is needed
or we need to replace their pre-column
or some other issues
also we look at the curiosity and in
field of metabolomics the gold standard
is to use
standard reference human plasma from
honest 1915
so in this human plasma there's a
reference values for
several or a lot of analytes and in this
case we plotted the ones
that were overlapping in our method so
in the gray bars you can see what the
certified value so the value that we
should
detect or should measure in the these
human plasma samples
and the blue one they're actually the
measured value the one that we got and
as you can see for those now
analyzed with our web measures with our
method we are really really good at
agreement
also we looked at precision meaning how
the biological replicates compared with
technical replicates
so what of course you want to see the
technical replica technical
repeatability
is better than biological repeatability
so and here i plotted the
rsds of four cell lines where we had
three biological replicas per cell line
and then i have rsd plotted in blue for
three repeated injections
and as you can see from most of or all
detected analytes
metabolites the rsd of repeated
injections
is much lower than rsd of biological
replicates and for majority of
metabolites it was really lower than
hard
than 10 percent this shows the precision
is really good for this method
also this is large-scale studies that we
want to use
this method for it's also important to
have this intraday repeatability
so meaning if i have my sample measured
today
and i measured it on a day in one month
do i get the same results
and here we have done this exact
experiment so we measured samples in
december
they were measured in january we plotted
the results and also they
obtained values in a really really good
agreement so also the interdependability
is quite good for this method
so to sum up what we have done with this
exxon dmr method
so we took it as is we implemented in
our lab
and then we were able to clean out let's
say the
provided mrnam database to be 198
metabolites
we were able to include 68 internal
standards in the method
for data processing we also spent quite
a lot of time and effort to really
optimize integration parameters for
every single compound
we also optimize internal standard setup
so that the selected
internal standards provide the most
optimal performance
for the given analyte and we also have
worked a lot to really implement
appropriate calibration set for every
single metabolite
with all this work what actually
resulted is that now instead of relative
quantification
we can really get absolute
quantification for 191 compounds
and the final workflow what it provides
us is
that we can analyze 96 samples within
uh four days so this is not the most
high throughput essay but as i said the
throughput is not the key here it's
really the
robustness and the long-term performance
so with that i would like to thank my
colleagues at the proteomics
metropolitan facility
daniel and bettina who did the most work
on this project
also my other colleagues from santa bay
in bitterly and also people from ageland
and thank you for attention and i'm
happy to take any questions
and thank you dr clavin for that
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
and if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now
just click on the ask the question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
let's take a look at our audience member
questions coming in now
dr clavin which internal standard
is used for metabolites where there is
no
isotopically labeled compound in the
method
yes thank you for this question so from
our experience what we have seen
is that of course in the method we don't
have all internal standards so we need
to assign different
compounds for uh different compounds as
internal stones from those metabolites
and from our experience what we have
seen is that retention time plays a
major role there
so in terms of accuracy and precision so
the closer the retention time for the
compound and internal standard
the better the performance of the
compounds so in this regard we really
took the closest eluting and uh
compound as internal standard for those
ones we didn't have isoprenable internal
standards
thank you for that and we actually have
one more question from our audience
can method be used to in positive
ionization mode
no unfortunately this is one of the it's
the main limitation of the method so as
uh separation relies on ion paragraphs
which is a tributary amine in this case
it's not possible to detect compounds in
positive detection mode
and thank you so much and dr clavin i
want to thank you for your presentation
today did you want to provide any
closing remarks to our audience before
we close
uh no i just want to thank all for your
time and attention and
also for the great questions thank you
thank you again for your time today and
for your important research
and before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period um will be addressed
by our speaker via contact information
you provided at the time
of the registration um this webcast can
be viewed on demand
through may of 2021 until next time
have a great day and stay safe bye